hey guys Sean McGinnis here and I've
just spent a little over an hour messing
around with watchdogs
I say messing around because we've seen
a lot of the story missions so far but
this was really our first chance to just
wander around and explore the world
without any limitations now there are
two ways to do that
you either stroll around like some
average Joe or you pull out your phone
and explore Chicago like a badass hacker
this is when the city really comes to
life because everyone you pass by can be
profiled by a smart phone hacking
professions salaries web browsing habits
you name it you can even eavesdrop on
phone calls and read their text messages
it's a nice little touch to add some
real character to the city but it's not
just for show you might be able to hack
somebody's bank account and withdraw
their money from an ATM other times you
can find likely criminals and tail them
for a little street justice now like a
lot of you v Montreal games watchdogs is
very complex when it comes to just how
many gameplay systems that uses take
hacking for example there are CTOs
watchtowers that you can tap into in
order to unlock new hacking
opportunities on the map a bit like the
towers and Assassin's Creed as well as
an entire skill tree to learn new
abilities of course abilities require
skill points and that means doing
missions there's an entire stealth
system that plays a lot like Splinter
Cell or you can just run around with
guns blazing if that's what you prefer
personally I prefer watchdog stealth the
gunplay feels good but there's just so
much you can do in terms of hacking all
these different objects in the
environment plus if you want to spice
things up you can always steal cars and
get into a massive police chase
hopefully that gives you a little taste
of what it's like to play watchdogs if
you want even more information be sure
to check out my lengthy hands-on preview
on GameSpot calm